[Applause]
and finally new rule if insanity is
defined as doing the same thing over and
expecting a different result we have to
stop being insane in our approach to
fixing the environment and try something
new
I I
don't know what will work but I know
what didn't work asking people to be
good
trying to convince our citizens and
other countries to use less and pollute
less sacrifice more
um when you tell humans if you do these
environmentally friendly things we can
all continue to live their response is
what's in it for me
so just to be clear I do still believe
very much that climate change is an
emergency but I don't think we're going
to win it by grocery shopping with a
laundry bag
or Banning the gas stoves or imagining a
human can really drink this through a
paper straw
foreign
on your phone can use more energy in a
day than the refrigerator but no one is
going to give that up
we'd have to go back to having sex with
people we know
[Applause]
and we all must be aware by now that
what buying everything from Amazon does
to the environment
but that we stopped no the verdict is in
humans are not good people
[Applause]
it's just not in us including me and I'm
tired of living a well not a lie but
it's also something I never mentioned
but it's a new year and I'd like to come
clean
my name is Bill
[Laughter]
and I fly private foreign
and so does every other person who calls
themselves an environmentalist who can
now enjoy this fun photo collage of some
of your favorite Stars
[Laughter]
politicians who speak about the need to
reduce our carbon footprint but who are
always on private planes
that's right all of them
if you don't see a celebrity's picture
here it's because we weren't allowed to
use it
[Laughter]
series got canceled
all the environmentalists of Hollywood
and Washington do it their position on
climate change is we must do more to
stop pouring carbon into the air except
for me when I want to go somewhere and
then I take a private jet
it turns out there is one thing in this
world that is completely impossible to
resist and this is it
it's like heroin
if you if you do it once you'll never
stop
there are two kinds of people in the
world those who fly private and those
who would if they could
[Applause]
a third category those who could but do
not does not exist
except for Ed Begley and Greta tunberg
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and that's why you never see a picture
of her smiling
Ed and Greta that's who walks the walk
everyone else is full of and I'm
done being full of I can take being
a bad environmentalist because almost
all of us are but I can't take being a
hypocrite
now I always Justified renting a plane
because I only used it for work and
literally could not get to most of my
stand-up gigs on time any other way how
do you think I did it all those years I
said good night here at 8 pm I was on
stage in Vegas at 10.
but I don't need to do stand-up like
tomorrow night in Albuquerque
[Applause]
and outside of heads of state almost
everyone else could fly commercial why
don't they
ask anyone who tried to get home for
Christmas last year
and don't tell me the younger generation
is better they're not they're just
poorer
they're actually worse this is who they
look up to the family where everyone has
their own private jet and kids love
Bitcoin which to determine the value of
takes an amount of computer processes
processing that uses more electricity
than some whole countries kids could
have rejected that but they didn't they
love it why because they want to be rich
why so they can fly private
foreign
can resist it John Kerry is our climate
Czar and he uses a private jet it's like
if the Secretary of Homeland Security
smuggled drugs in his butt
people take Jets to environmental
conferences if you could run TED talks
on hypocrisy you wouldn't need coal
but sorry not sorry I tried to do my
part for the environment I never had
kids the one thing worse for the planet
than private jet
it's true because then they have kids
I had the first generation Prius in 2001
it looked like a Tylenol gel cap
I was always handing my keys to valets
who were driving a better car than me
the first Tesla in 2010 and honestly
both these cars sucked
the Tesla came up to about here on me if
I if I had a hard on I couldn't fit in
this thing
but both times I said to myself okay
I'll take one for the team because I
have a platform so I'll do the right
thing and then everybody will follow
every people will
nobody followed in 2021 80 percent of
new vehicles weren't electric or an even
hybrid they weren't even cars they were
SUVs and trucks that's what people want
in 1973 the share of global electricity
generated by coal was 38 percent you
know what it was 46 years later in 2019
after all the talk and all the trying
37 percent
you know what percentage of plastic gets
recycled
five
percent those blue bims that are
everywhere they're not full of bottles
they're full of
can
can you blame us for being a little
cynical when you find out that all that
plastic that we've been painstakingly
separating out for the last 20 years all
goes to the same place anyway
so yes it's fun to laugh at powerful
people that that's how I can afford to
fly private
[Applause]
but we need to get serious really more
nuclear
moving way more money into research and
development I don't know but something
serious because the real technological
problem is the way people are wired I
know it's easier just to blame Taylor
Swift's plane but honestly
do you want to be stuck on Southwest
with a Pissed Off Taylor Swift